oh if you're gonna revisit your
childhood probably a good thing that was
that's a humor about it okay folks
patreon sponsored review actually had to
add to negotiate this a little
originally um the request was to review
Thundercats ho which was a sort of
cobbled together movie which was a
compilation of a bunch of season two
episodes of Thundercats I ended up
having a little bit of trouble securing
those and upon get it you know talking a
little bit further with the person who
commissioned it they agreed to let me
just deal with sort of the premiere
episodes of of Thundercats I'm not gonna
go through it beat for beat and this is
not really gonna be a standard review
this is more a me taking off the Rose
tinted glasses kind of experience
because I grew up with Thundercats
unlike when I reviewed the Transformers
movie we you know and transformers was
something that I didn't watch growing up
so I had no investment and was pretty
much coming in too cold I mean I knew
the general premise of transformers but
you know I wasn't something I'd ever
watch Thundercats on the other hand was
basically one of three cartoons that I
was really into when I was young
those being Thundercats he-man and the
Masters of the Universe and the Real
Ghostbusters now the Real Ghostbusters I
actually have the complete set of and
episode by episode quality can vary
wildly but I was really delighted to go
back and watch that and realize that the
episodes that I remembers being good are
really good
still I have kind of deliberately
avoided going back and revisiting he-man
and the Masters of the Universe because
the few times I've caught like a little
snippets I'm like well how I do
remember looking that much like crap and
my memories of Thundercats have been
pretty good but I haven't had occasion
to go back and see it before this here's
the thing that I'll say memory is a
really funny thing because my memory of
how this show looked in terms of the
sophistication of the animation the
detail of the drawing the use of colors
and shade and and effects and things
like that it's basically like my mind
took the visual quality that's in the
opening the opening credits and the
theme and projected that out and sort of
put it in like an Instagram filter over
my memories of the actual episodes so in
my mind in my memory the in episode
animation was as good as that opening
sequence it's not so there's thing one I
mean I've still got a little bit of an
affection for the quality of this
animation cuz it's rankin/bass and I can
identify things about rankin/bass
animation that just I just like and
there's funny as much as I love
rankin/bass I I never watched their
their Christmas stuff not growing up
anyway I've seen most of it now but like
I grew up on the Hobbit and and they're
like the one Christmas thing of theirs
that I did grow up on was the twas the
night before Christmas with the mice and
The Last Unicorn and there I can catch
bits of that kind of style and approach
to animation here and a lot of it's in
the designs they've there's a very
distinct mouth movement to a rankin/bass
2d animation but boy the animations
rough at points which you know I knew
was gonna happen going in because you
know time and nostalgia have given it a
much glassy or look in my mind then it
ever had but I don't want to dwell too
much on the visuals because I do think
there's still
pretty good for the time um then and
they're pretty it's pretty standard for
the time and I think it's on par and I
honestly in the sort of upper range of
animation of things like the shows I
already mentioned or transformers or GI
Joe
Thundercats conceptually it's pulling
from a lot of stuff like all over the
place especially going back and seeing
the the first few episodes and like
really solidifying how many things it's
pulling its influences from so broadly
speaking in terms of general tone it's
taking the most obvious inspiration from
he-man because it is doing that sort of
similar combining of of very fantastical
elements with sci-fi elements so you
have people who will cast spells in the
same show as you know they have laser
guns so that kind of amalgamation feels
very borrowed from from he-man and the
Masters of the Universe so there's that
but there's like right off the bat
there's like a Superman comparison
because um the Thundercats watch their
home planet of thundera explode and then
it becomes like for a hot second a weird
Star Wars thing as a bunch of other
ships that are in their fleet get blown
up by the mutants there's a lot of yank
stuff that I can like see the stitches
of how this this thing was Frankenstein
together and like so many other action
and action figure more specifically
focused shows of the time yeah there's a
you can see how much the intent of what
gets to be a toy was put into this the
thundertank gets used fairly frequently
because that was a toy that you could
get for them you got to be sure you show
off every character wielding whatever
their weapon is that's for both hero and
villain so that you can sell within the
context of the show how cool these guys
would be to play with as action figures
I think you're so got something
Katz's somewhere I am like as I grew up
I sold I sold off a lot of my stuff in
yard sales I think I've still got a
little bit though yeah I should dig that
up one of these days uh in any case the
I think the the thing that was the
biggest surprise for me going back and
rewatching this the voice acting is
terrible like were really bad and almost
across the board there's uh there's like
a couple of performances that I would
call good a few that are fine and then
but some of the key ones are really
really bad the main thing is they're the
the only of the hero characters so the
hero characters be the Thundercats being
lion-o Panthro Tygra Cheetara
wilykit wilykat you can count jaga I
suppose if you want to and snarf the
only performance out of those that I
would call genuinely good as Panthro
because he's the only one who feels like
he has any personality at all and you
built it just from the junk you
scrounged from the spaceship salvaged
from equipment I salvaged from the ship
the rest of them I think the biggest
offender being Tygra he's like I was
gonna say he's like the Cyclops of this
group but that's an insult to Cyclops
like that's how wooden and stiff this
guy is in the meantime you are our guest
our home is open to you and then lion-o
is similar and I had also forgotten I
had forgotten that part of the conceit
with lion-o is that he's actually much
younger than he looks like that
the that the trip to Third Earth which
complete random sidebar mama refers to
it as having once been called first
Earth and and literally calls things
Egyptian at one
doesn't ever get established like in the
comics or other material that this is
actually like was at some point the
earth we know it was also the third
planet out on the solar system that they
landed in I'm just saying anyways the
trip it said you know they have to kind
of go into a sort of a stasis thing and
he he ages physically but not mentally
while he's in there he comes out he's
full-grown bristle they never actually
address why it happened to him but not
to wilykit wilykat they stay young that
never actually gets addressed and my
memory is that it doesn't come up for
very long
how young lion-o actually is like I get
that they wanted to like him to be the
inexperienced leader without actually
having a kid lead them I guess but it's
it's a conceit that I don't think the
show well even in these episodes it
doesn't do much with it's just kind of
there but God speaking and coming back
to the voice acting I really did not
appreciate how irritating snarf is I
don't trust him snarf did you say that
you don't even know him just the
smashing tuition that's all like and I
don't know what it was about these kinds
of cartoons that felt the need to have
this kind of character because snarf is
to Orko is to Jude Slimer from the Real
Ghostbusters like these kinds of weird
sidekick II annoying voiced almost never
actually helped whole supposedly funny
characters were in a lot of children's
media and to be fair as a kid I actually
liked all three of these characters I
liked Torico I liked Slimer
I liked snarf I think I liked snarf
probably the least of those three but
like I did like these characters but man
part of its the voice and just the it
sounds awful it is a grating voice but
also the person
that goes with it he is whiny as a hack
he's kind of you know what he's kind of
guy he's kind of got c-3po personality
in this whiny nasally voice y-you know
oh my gosh yeah that that gets older
real quick the villains are only
slightly better
mom remember but it's a little too kind
of gargle II for me in a way that kind
of kills intonation and just kind of
muddles it you're standing you're and I
think slides probably has the best vocal
performance of the villains monkey and
and Jack Ohman are fine they get the job
done although I bring up them there's
some bizarre plot holes in this in this
thing
so everybody's after the eye of thundera
which is in the sword of omens we don't
know why like it's just kind of presumed
that like mom Rob wants its power we
don't really know why the mutants want
it and it's actually established I
forget I forgot how early was
established its established by Episode
five or six that the high of thundera
and the sword of omens cannot be used
for evil purposes which basically means
there's literally nothing that mum Rock
can do with the thing if he ever got his
hands on it
so whoa whoa what's he doing and what
the mutants like I could possibly buy a
lower level motivation like they just
wanna I don't know power or weapon with
it sell it I don't know but the weird
thing here is that we open with the
mutants hunting them down in space and
then there's the the multi year
a 10-year trip where jog you know dies
getting them there and lion-o grows up
in stasis and they land on Third Earth
and then the mutants show up the mutants
tracked them for ten years really that I
if you're going to show that level of
commitment I think I need a slightly
stronger motivation on this also funny
thing with the mutants is then initially
there's a lot of them like there's a lot
of reptilians a lot of the simian
characters a lot of the jackal Minh but
after the first episode we only really
see one of each there was like a vague
reference I saw somewhere to there being
more of them but like it just becomes
one of each in and I don't know if we're
supposed to believe that there are other
mutants that are like under the command
of each one of these three types or if
they're just gone cuz we like we really
never see them again and then oh boy
then there's the ro-bear berbils the if
c-3po mated with an Ewok you get these
things Wow I don't like that was a that
those are weird to me because that's a
toy I don't even remember seeing I'm
like whoa because normally the answer
for why is that there is a cuz it's a
toy I don't remember ever seeing those
that was that was a weird one and you
know I'm making fun of this but like
these are the sorts of things that I
either didn't realize didn't appreciate
didn't notice when I was a kid or just
had forgotten about and so that's just
kind of where my head's at
revisiting this thing there is some
stuff that's still really good though
first of all I like the design I like
the design of most of the characters the
villains the monsters it's pretty good
some of the one-off characters that only
show up for one episode the
those are a little more lazy but the the
main core group well-designed across the
board I think as far as the heroes go I
always liked the look of Cheetara the
best but I like I said Panthro is really
the only one with much of a personality
and overall their costumes are pretty
good once they have them on because
another thing I'd forgotten in the very
first episode there they're naked they
just walk around naked yet but there's
also a seam like where the where the
thigh meets the hip and that's and
that's really weird to me because that's
like the seam where the leg would Bend
on an action figure so I don't even know
I got hey that was so weird like I feel
like I'm saying it's so weird a lot in
that it's a weird show it really is but
anyways I like the designs I love the
transformation of mom or the music now
obviously I say the music and a lot of
people are gonna think of it be music
[Music]
which is very good but I'll say the
incidental music used in episode is
pretty good as well
um you know just the the sort of danger
didn't any kind of music that kicks in
or the sort of mysterious cynthy thing
when lion-o holds up the the sword of
omens and does the sight beyond sight
thing
[Music]
that's a cool little bit of music it's
across the board it's it's a pretty good
pretty good soundtrack to this obviously
you you watch these episodes
back-to-back and you quickly realize oh
they just they have like five music
tracks that they just drop in at
appropriate places but they're well-made
music tracks especially for this kind of
thing so I like those a lot and going
back to this as an adult I think it does
kind of gain a little bit of an mst3k
thing because the line readings are so
stiff and like oh my god chitara with
some of her line readings she got this
warble in her voice I gotta know where
like thunder died did you use aged like
by 40 years in the course of that
sentence what the heck was that
so there's things like that that way
that come on with the vocal performances
and then there's just all the the story
oddities like like the way that
characters react just to lion-o sends up
a signal and like villains are going oh
it's like effectively ugh it was turn a
skylight yes that means more of them are
coming but like really or mama like I
completely miss remembered mumm-ra's
reaction to his to his reflection which
is how he gets defeated the very first
time and like it's a cool concept but
like the visual he gets so it's not what
I remember being and it's way weirder
away walk here than I remember being and
like there's a unicorn that gives lion-o
a ring why would a unicorn have a ring
and why does Cheetara on her morning run
just like stop running and pass out did
she normally like on a daily basis run
so hard that she passes out there's some
of the really weird occupants of of
third earth like to my memory like it
was mostly the Thundercats running into
the mutants and mum run then later the
lunataks but like there's weird pirates
and and and other odd native characters
that are just kind of here and hanging
around and this show is way weird
than I remember it being and if you
don't mind laughing at something you
used to take seriously yeah I did have
fun revisiting this it is ridiculous
though Thundercats
at the very least the opening sort of
salvo of the first season because I'm
not in a position to say what did or
didn't change later on again my memories
of some of the later episodes maybe
they're just as rose-tinted as my
memories of these were maybe the show
actually did get better as it went along
I don't know maybe maybe someday I'll
find out but for now Thundercats what do
you what do you think about it what is
your memory of it what was the last time
you saw it like seriously
whatever your thoughts are drops let me
know in the comments let's talk about a
whole bunch of stuff to do buttons links
and patreon and social media and my book
and p.o box blah blah blah blah that's
all down in the description click on the
links cuz they'll take you places or you
also don't have to because at the end of
the day folks
you're the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]